foreign
how do I start preparing now to be the
best dad I can be how do I reframe my
own personal goals do I have to like put
them all down sounds like you are
excited to be a dad you love the you
love your wife and you're kind of pissed
because you had stuff that you wanted to
do
[Music]
what up what up what up this is John
with Dr John deloney's show the greatest
mental health and marriage parenting
podcast ever the dose of
whatever's going on in the world some
education talk and some politics and
just kidding we don't talk politics ever
because I think it's a waste of my life
hope you're doing well don't forget the
five star reviews and if you just said
thought to yourself politics is not a
waste politics is life probably not the
show for you but if you thought oh thank
God a place we're just gonna talk about
how to be better humans
this is the podcast for you please leave
your five star reviews tell your friends
even if you only have one tell that one
if you got a bunch tell them all and
don't forget you can really support this
podcast and more importantly than
supporting our Knuckleheads is you can
get this out to other people it throws
it up in the algorithms when you simply
just hit the Subscribe button cost you
nothing
um except a little tiny piece of your
soul that you give to the Googles into
the yahoos into whoever uh the YouTubes
but
we're grateful for your little piece uh
for the little piece of your soul and
speaking of 5
Soul Kelly
showed up with coffee today
got that text this morning what do you
want what kind of coffee do you want my
heart
started beating a little bit faster I
didn't know you had it in you I'm so
grateful
well I won't do it again
I'm nice
I for one knew you were capable of this
watch this Kelly thank you Ben see every
team has that guy on it I love you Mom I
love you Mom all right let's go to Dan
in Raleigh North Carolina what's up Dan
hey doing well how are you outstanding
brother what's up
yeah so um I just found out a few weeks
ago that my wife is pregnant with our
first baby all right way to go man can I
cheer for you
sure way to go dude how old are you
I'm 32. I just said way to go dude like
you you accomplished like you did the
high jump or something
um I'll say I'm I'm as a fellow Dad I'm
celebrating with you very cool yeah so
congrats man
um thanks yeah and my my question is
like how do I start preparing now like
to be the best that I can be and in
particular like how do I think about or
reframe some of like my own personal
goals because I don't want to be like
you know I hear a lot of people as you
know later in life like oh I should have
been more oriented towards my family
than career or goals but there's also an
element where like do I have to like put
them all down you know what I mean so
just kind of look for some guidance and
wisdom on how do I
integrate those two things well if that
makes sense okay can I ask you
um can I ask you some direct questions
yeah okay your language that you just
used to to ask your question here's what
it really sounds like
okay sounds like you are excited to be a
dad you love the you love your wife you
love the idea of you already probably
start loving this baby
and you're kind of pissed because you
had stuff that you wanted to do
and we don't have any place in our
culture anymore to say like
like it's happening am I off or am I
right
you're you're like you're on to it I I
wouldn't say that I'm pissed as much I'm
just sort of like okay like a little
bummed out but not I wouldn't say I'm
like angry I'm not like oh my gosh like
you're taking my life away but just sort
of like okay okay I know I need to
rethink this and I'm bummed about it but
how do I like do it both well maybe that
makes sense maybe that doesn't
absolutely absolutely I
absolutely hate this idea that we're not
allowed to have the full spectrum of
feelings anymore or we're some kind of
bad person
right
um moms get this a lot too with
they can't stay home with their kids
because you should be out contributing
financially and you can't work because
you should be home with the kids and
dads you know you should be fully
present and never ever look at a
smartphone ever you're a terrible father
and you should be out making six figures
and grinding and crushing and working
out four hours a day nobody can win
anymore right yeah and there's no way to
just say dude I'm really excited and God
Lee had a lot of plans man and I'm gonna
have to change all that crap up or yeah
um so anyway we'll we'll just say there
so I want to give you permission to have
the full spectrum of feelings as you go
along this this adventure okay yeah you
can really really love this toddler and
be super annoyed with how much it cries
and poops and by the way it poops 10x
what you think it's going to it's
unbelievable how much crap comes out of
a baby it's staggering
um and so
can I ask you this is there is it true
bummed out disappointment or underneath
all of this is there a fear like oh this
is happening I'm about to be a dad
I mean there's definitely a little bit
of that fear
um that happened way faster than you
know like a lot of people will talk
about we've been trying for you know a
long time and it's not and for us it was
the opposite experience so it's
definitely a little bit like we were
talking we're like Hey we're like we
want to start thinking about a family
like and then it just happened really
quickly so there's a bit of like just
shock Factor
um you all got pregnant from just a
conversation man way to go Dan uh it
felt that way fertile Myrtle over there
okay so
um what did you have planned
so like the big ones for me is I'm just
a big Backpacker and like hiker and so
like I've always wanted to do a through
hike of like the Appalachian Trail or
maybe like
um the Pacific Crest Trail or like the W
Trek and patagon like the adventures
that unfortunately take a good chunk of
time it's not like oh I can just put
this into like my daily routine or
weekly rhythms of life it's like I have
to sort of stop them to do some of those
things
um so it goes like that I was like oh
like I'd be away from my family for five
months to do the at you know
um I think it's that's the majority of
like the goals that I'm like thinking
through it's not like man I want to like
have
a certain amount of money by a certain
age or anything like that it's it's more
of was that yeah is that is that a
realistic
before you had kids was that something
you had on the calendar to do or is that
one of those things that's been floating
out there for a while
it's something that it wasn't on the
calendar but my wife and I were talking
pretty regularly about hey like this is
a goal I really want to do I've read up
on it I've studied it I do backpacking
trips I've like been building up my gear
like it's something I do like want to do
it's not just oh maybe one day that
would be fun like there was like working
and plans towards it even if it wasn't
like on the calendar Okay so
I would say if you're not doing
something like that professionally right
um like let's say you were a touring
musician and you're gonna be on the road
five years or you're an actor and you're
gonna be on the road or you're an
engineer on location and you got to go
away for three months that's life or you
get deployed and you're gone for a year
so think through those moments those
kids do great if they've got a great
Network and there's intentionality and
and connection along the way there
um those kids do great those are those
are situations that people plan for well
in advance and they know they're coming
right I'm I'm actually more concerned
about the financial implications like
you probably can't afford to take a year
a half a year off of work
with a with a little kid right I mean it
just changes the equation up here's what
I didn't know on this side on your side
of parenting
um and for all of you who think hunting
is evil great uh high five us support
you hit the fast forward button a couple
of times here okay I always
um
I did not understand how much better I
would feel how much more excited I was
how much more joy I felt when my son
shot a deer
and I got to see the excitement he put
all that work in he's been practicing
I'm really strict on how much he
practices before he goes out in the
field
and how he felt like he's providing for
the like it was incredible and dude it's
I've never I've always been like The
Jealous Guy
or the no no I I get the I'm gonna I'm
gonna get the best spot I'm gonna endude
everything shifted and so what I'll tell
you here is having these goals
incredible working towards them in a
rational way financially time wise
awesome
I almost guarantee that your priorities
will shift
in two to three to four to five years
right dramatically and it's hard to see
it on this side so I would begin to make
this plan very very concrete
how much dollars would it actually take
how much time would it actually take
pick one of the trails and either knock
it out in the next three months or four
months before your kid comes along or
say this is what I want to do when my
son or daughter turns 16 we're gonna do
this adventure together
and right now it doesn't feel like that
would be cool
I promise you my son and I are going on
a big elk hunt in December with some
great friends we met in Utah
dude I never in a million years thought
I'd want a 12 year old tagging along
with me and I can't wait now
yeah totally different you know what I'm
saying and if I come home with nothing
and I got to spend that time with my son
incred like I'm I'm so excited about it
um it has nothing to do with the big
goal that I've always been chasing does
that make sense
no yeah I think that makes sense of and
I think it's helpful to hear because I
think
uh one piece of context is that like my
parents didn't bring me into a lot of
like the things that they loved to do
like when I was like a kid it was sort
of the like I felt like my parents were
like we have to be good parents so like
you know and they were like they ran me
around to like soccer and like they
cared for me really well and provided
for me really well and I have great
relationships with them now but it was
always like I didn't feel like we were
like I didn't really know what my
parents loved doing and so like I
haven't had that picture of like hey
like how would how do you integrate like
your kids into like some of the things
that you love doing whether that's you
know hiking backpacking or hunting for
you right so yeah so to hear your
perspective on that dude
um
some of the my greatest memories as a
child my dad his side hustle when I was
a kid this is gonna sound crazy this is
many many years ago but his side hustle
was catching
venomous snakes and he had a friend who
was a taxidermist and he would sell
and so I have memories and photos of me
and my dad when I was four and five and
six out in the woods Woods Woods
and heart racing fast you know getting
nervous watching my dad do his thing and
dude I became obsessed with catching
snakes when I was a kid became a reptile
goofball my brother got in on it then my
brother became the director of a reptile
house at a zoo and then now my son has a
snake in his wreck it created a legacy
and here's what it was my dad brought me
alongside something that he loved doing
mm-hmm when my dad took me shooting with
him when my dad played catch with me
outside like the greatest gift you can
give your kid is not signing him up for
another travel sport I don't care how
much they beg
the greatest gift you can give your kid
is to teach them what passion and joy
and fun looks and feels like
dude if you start taking your kid on
small backpacking trips before they can
even talk or walk in one of those
backpacks with their feet hang out you
know what I mean like the oh yeah those
things are so cool dude dude you're
teaching your kid love for the outdoors
they're gonna feel the Joy on you
mm-hmm and the greatest gift dads can
pass along to their kids is oh Dad loves
life
this is the thing that brings dad's Joy
whether you're fixing a car whether
you're going hiking whether you're going
hunting whether you're playing chess and
like I also love playing guitar my kids
have opted out of that I tried man I've
tried and tried and tried and tried they
don't want anything to do with that's
totally cool but they do know dad's got
his things
right right and when I'm downstairs in
the in the garage jamming too loud and I
got the amps turned up too loud and I'm
just pretending I was a high school
metal star which I always wanted to be
come on somebody make this happen for me
um they roll their eyes but they smile
um you see what I'm saying
so yeah no that makes sense pass along
those take your kids with it's going to
be amazing dude and it's not gonna be
the same Adventure that you thought and
I don't have any hesitation or promise
if your kid got to watch you save money
and exercise and work out
and build up to a huge trip that they
were too small for but you went on for
three months
right if you bring them along maybe not
on the trip but you bring them along on
the planning on the building stages
you're teaching them how to read a
topographic map you're looking at
pictures on the internet of where Dad's
gonna be you have a little thing on the
wall that shows how much money you're
saving As you move up
um they go on miniature hikes to train
with you you know what I mean before the
big hike and they wish you goodbye and
you and your wife have this all squared
away financially and child care wise and
all that dude that's awesome and you
come back and show the pictures to your
kids that's fantastic man my kids don't
fully understand what I do when I'm out
on the road like I can say hey I'm
meeting with Business Leaders behind
closed doors
they're like okay okay whatever or I'm
speaking at this event okay whatever
I've started now and I speak at Live
Events I just get a quick video on stage
of the crowd screaming and hollering so
I take that and show that to my kids and
they're like oh that's what you're doing
from your eyes out to the audience right
so I bring them along with me even
though they're not there that's okay if
you start hiding from your family
because raising a kid's heart man it's
hard you don't know what you're doing
and there's not a lot of men who will
talk to you about how to do it right
if you start using hiking if you start
using planning for this imaginary
fantasy hike that you're never going to
go on you're going to go on when you're
80. as a way to distract yourself or
numb yourself from the realities of
parenting that's when it becomes an
addiction it becomes a problem
and that's when your kids begin to say
hey loves whatever he's planning over
there more than me
and that's no bueno that's not good
um it doesn't sound like you and let me
go by Circle back to the beginning it's
okay to be disappointed it's okay to
think ah I want to have a million
dollars I want to have graduated college
I wanted to have whatever cool that's
all real and good and true
a dad
so incredible man everything in your
life is going to change it's gonna be
the worst best thing that ever happened
to you it's going to be the funnest most
exhausting thing that's ever happened to
you and you're gonna have to go down a
rabbit hole to figure out who you really
are welcome to the adventure my brother
it is excitement from here on out we'll
be right back
hey guys deloney here and I've got a
word from our sponsor whoop if you've
listened to the show for any length of
time you know I'm a major nerd about
Fitness sleep mental health and building
healthier life habits and let's just say
this whoop makes my nerd heart so happy
one reason I love whoop is that it's not
like all the other fitness trackers that
mix in a watch in laser lights and
smiley faces and a million notifications
and reminders that you you need to get
your steps in no whoop is a fitness
wearable that actually looks cool and
it's comfortable and it gives you data
that really matters it breaks down your
recovery your sleep and your daily
strain into a format that's easy to
interpret and some days I wake up in the
green and this tells me that I'm ready
to go attack the day and other days I
wake up in the red and I know that I
gotta take it easy and I can look back
in time and see how I got there if
you're working to be intentional and
build healthier habits whoop can help
you get there start keeping an eye on
your health and wellness at a deeper
level go to whoop dot com that's
w-h-o-oop.com and use promo code deloni
to get 10 off your order today
all right we are back um hey my favorite
part of today so far is that Kelly
brought coffee for everybody
except for Andrew nope nope nope we're
not doing this except for Andrew so good
there's a whole team there's even Ike
back here who's just the assistant to
the regional manager he is the backup to
the backup back there he got coffee
actually he got tea because he's that
guy every every group has the one that's
like I don't do coffee just tea
um the last time I was in a group that
did that you knew it was Jocko like hey
you guys want coffee coffee coffee yeah
yeah yeah uh I just drink tea and we're
all like yes sir and then I thought I
should probably just drink tea okay I'm
gonna I am defending myself even though
I don't feel like I have to
[Laughter]
it's actually Nathan keeler's fault who
sometimes does this job as well because
when I asked who's going to be in there
today so I can buy him coffee and Nathan
was like I'm going to be in there but I
don't want anything to thank you
and I walk in and apparently they had
switched so it's it's on Nathan
we're gonna throw him under that bus hmm
and just as we teach as I teach often on
this show the Cornerstone of good mental
health is having somebody else to blame
so well done Kelly hope that feels good
all right let's go to Megan in the home
of Grunge music Seattle what's up Megan
hi I'm excited and nervous to talk to
you I'm excited and more nervous I
promise so we'll get through this
together what's up
my question is my son
is 18 in about 10 days and he's not
motivated to
um
get a job or a car or a license he's not
doing well in high school and he has no
interest in college or training
so how do I motivate him
probably go back in time 12 years and
start there start there
um
have you tried to love him throughout
his childhood by doing a lot of stuff
for him
yes
I heard
we're gonna go with a whoopsy doo on
that one yes just for the sake of being
a single mom getting things done trying
to keep things moving
um and not realizing the consequences of
that on him yeah well hey high five to
you I'll give you a hug if we're if you
were we're in the same room and
um the fact that you've wrapped your
head around that is incredible good for
you
um also I don't want you to shoulder all
of this okay
um
when's the last time he had a stable
male presence in his life that actually
modeled what was coming next for him
he has has not okay
um his dad has been out of the picture
um pretty much from the beginning and I
was married when he was a young kid and
that only lasted a couple years it was
turned abusive and it was a bad divorce
and everything so that was
um that and then I have dated but he's
not had
like nobody from like a church or
anything like that that's kind of stuck
around okay
so if we wanna
um get inside his head and pretend to
look out his eyes as he scans the world
um he has no
there is no path forward
he doesn't see a path for let me put it
that way because he doesn't have anyone
who's modeled that for him
and I put that squirrely at the feet of
Dad
absolute dismal failure on Dad
okay
um
dad failed the Sun and so now we have an
18 year old who has relied heavily on
the love of his mom and probably taken
advantage of it let's be honest
um and I'm not gonna blame him he's a
kid any kids are gonna go as far as the
boundaries that they're given allow them
and um
and then when we're saying okay what's
next what are you gonna do
there's no picture in his head right
like I had pictures of my dad getting up
and putting a suit on when he was a
detective and then when he quit to
become a minister I had a picture of him
putting on like I just had a visual of
what that he doesn't have that
and so
many kids in his place have gone to one
of two places the internet
where they were it's full of images and
pictures of what this thing is supposed
to look like this thing called manhood
this thing called what comes next
or they just Retreat inside of
themselves and it sounds like that's
what your son's done
okay
here is the hardest I'm going to quote
my friend Henry cloud and Henry's become
a great friend
um he wrote the original book called
Boundaries which is one of the greatest
books ever
um
here's his quote okay
your son is
well I'll walk you through it and I'll
give you his quote your son right now
has absolutely no reason to think about
college none okay he has absolutely no
reason to get a job he has no reason to
graduate high school zero
he he actually says that when I ask him
he'll he's like why yeah why like for
what because here's why yeah his
remember we were talking about looking
out at the world through his eyes
his bed is always going to be there
and food is always going to magically
show up in the in the in the
refrigerator
right and he's always gonna magically
just use somebody else's bathroom yours
and all those things like the car is
just gonna continually be in the
driveway for him to use and so Henry's
famous quote which I love is he's gonna
have to get some problems
okay and this is where you are really
going to struggle because
you are going to feel your body is going
to feel his whining and pushing back and
crying and having to learn new things
and possibly ending up rooming in a
place that you don't like or hanging out
with people you know like you are going
to feel that as a maternal failure and
it's not
okay it's the greatest thing you could
do for him
create some problems see and that's
where I struggle with like
um where and when do I push uh you know
I don't know I think I mean given his
life his how far he's come thus far
I would give him six months
right and say Here's what happens at the
end of six months
you begin paying rent or you're out of
my house
yeah you are enrolled in college
okay or your rent doubles
you will also pay your portion of the
light bill and if you're going to sit
there and sit on the computer in the
video games all day you will pay 95
percent of our of our internet service
okay right and so I think it's I want
you to treat this as though it's a very
professional interaction
which is here like just the same as if
you worked in an office setting here's
what what this costs the reality here's
the real cost here's what portion of
this you're going to pay
okay okay and this is you loving him
like you've never loved him before
um and you can let him know I will go
shop apartments with you I'll even help
you my Dad paid for my first month's
um to the deposit my first apartment
like I don't prom with you helping him
out that way if you can afford it
um but we're gonna start a graduated
conversation here's how this has gone in
my house and my son's 12 and I told him
a month ago
after fall break we're starting a new
season in my house called the season of
excellence and he doesn't know this but
I'm taking him on a trip in October and
I can say this because this episode
won't air until we're back well he
doesn't listen to this anyway let's be
honest
um but I'm taking him on a trip and some
other guys from across the country are
going to meet us in a secret location
and we're gonna do a pretty cool thing
with him and with these other men
um and I'm going to begin treating him a
little bit different now we're having
different conversations
okay we're transitioning from him being
a little boy
that uh to where he's not a man but he
is entering into a new phase and I'm
calling it the season of excellence and
uh here's a good example this morning
um he got cereal
on his own and the the box was open and
when I got down and there was cereal
bits on the counter and I called him
down and I didn't yell I didn't scream I
didn't act like an idiot but I said part
of Excellence is leaving every
environment better than you found it
okay so before you leave son I want you
to take a look around and ask yourself
is this place better because I was here
or not
and I want him to do that in his
neighborhood in his community with his
wife one day with his spouse with his
kids with his home with his car I want
that to become a way he sees the world
right I don't want anyone calling this
show worse off after they talk to me
than before they call me right right so
I'm setting that stage now you're gonna
have to just do that in a very
accelerated fashion I got six years
before he turns 18 you've got six months
yes right and so I want you to get super
intentional
what are the things
you wish the man you married
how he had treated you what he knew
about the world what he knew about hard
work what he knew about all his things
um I wanted to push you I want you to
pick up a book called The intentional
father by John Tyson
okay okay and I know your mom works just
it it's going to be different but it is
what it is
um it's called the intentional father
it's phenomenal and it's a read through
a way to be intentional you're just
gonna have to compress this or maybe
you're gonna have to extend it most end
at 18 or 21 you might have to go a
little bit further but we're changing
this um we're transitioning this out
okay I also if you've got the ability to
find a man in your world not a romantic
partner but somebody who would step up
and begin to take him to breakfast or
lunch and
um ask him hard questions and challenge
him on things and teach him how to do
things like tie a tie and apply for
college and get a job and things like
that that would be fantastic
and yeah I can talk
that would be incredible so good man my
dad did that for other people other men
did that for me
okay um throughout my life and it's been
really really good
okay he's got to have a picture in his
head of what this is what this can look
like
right and make no mistake
you are shaking up his
um comfort zone in a dramatic way
yeah he will fight this he will say I
hate you he will fill in the blank fill
in the blank fill in the blank
yeah no he turns it back to me he says
if do you hate me like when I'm like and
I'm like no that [ __ ] hey that is just a
move that is just a move you're gonna
tell him
I am raising a man that is going to
contribute
to society
I am raising a young man who is going to
be healthy and be well and be a positive
contributor to this neighborhood to his
family to himself to his country to ever
to everybody
so that starts here you will make your
bed before you leave or tonight you will
have no sheets that's the choice you
make you get to choose whether do you
want sheets or no sheets
you will clean up after yourself you
will make your own breakfast I will
never ever do your laundry again ever
ever
congratulations
and if you don't have clean clothes
that's the choice you made
I will help you learn how to schedule
your time because you've never had to do
that before right so we're gonna break
this stuff down and Mom you're gonna
have to get super intentional probably
in a way you've never been
get very very intentional what are the
skills I want him to walk out of my home
with
how much time do I got left what is that
going to look like
and maybe this all starts with you
taking them out on a date taking them
out somewhere nice
and talking to him about your childhood
maybe in a way you never have take him
out and talk to him about who you dated
about his dad about your first husband
and walk him through how men have
treated you how it's gone how it hasn't
gone
and how man I I wish I'd done this one
differently with you and I didn't but
here we are
[Music]
and everything's gonna change in this
world
that's the great Henry Cloud says he's
gonna have to get some problems
he doesn't have they don't have to be
problematic
but we're gonna start putting challenges
and challenges in front of him and we're
gonna stop lifting his weights for him
hoping he's going to get strong
thank you so much for the call we'll be
right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free and that's what therapy can
help you do it gives you the tools you
need to do the problem solving in your
own life and that's why I love better
help better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours if you're ready to get
the tools that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloney to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right we're back let's take into
Moss let's go out to Flint Michigan and
talk to Nicole what's up Nicole
hi
Hi how are we doing how's it going party
ahead rocking on to the breaking down
what's up Happy Friday that's why not
right absolutely yep so what's up
um Okay so
I've had this question for as long as
I've been married which has been eight
years
um and I just I cannot I cannot seem to
figure it out and it's just going around
in a circle and it needs to get better
at this point
um so my question is how can I better
serve my husband's love language which
is acts of service I think because it
it's really communication is the the
thing and I think communication falls
into acts of service
um and it's he tells me that that's what
he needs more of is communication
um and why do you think communication
why do you think communication means
acts of service how do you get there
um I think because when he says
communication
it's like he wants me to work with him
or as a team like
um just
tell him how I like what I am planning
to do or
um I don't know just be on the same page
with things help him with things okay
the way you're and I'm smiling with you
right so you and I are hanging out right
we're not I'm not laughing at you the
way you're describing this is though
it's like he wants me to spray paint my
face blue and red and then sing Adele
songs in Spanish like you're describing
things that are so crazy but the way
you're saying it is like what you're
actually saying is
he wants me to like tell him what's on
my mind and involve him in plans like
super super rational things he's asking
for here so I don't know it's just hard
to explain like when it sounds like okay
go with me here and I've got two phds
that's how I'm able to figure this out
um what if you just uh
told him what you were thinking and
invited him along on the plans that you
had for that like of the things he's
asking for
no it's like I am like the the person
that handles our daily schedules and I
feel like I do a good job of telling
them what's going on and keeping him in
the loop it's like the little things
that come up
um that he just finds
that are becoming problems and I don't
feel like they're a problem or give me
an example like
for instance
um just recently and they're usually
like little things it's like
um we have water bottles for the kids
and
um we keep losing them and and we're
spending money and more water bottles
and he's like I think we should get some
more water bottles and I I'm like yeah
we should and in my head I'm thinking
like yeah I want to see if I can find
them first or
um I'll just have to buy some new ones I
guess if we can't find them but I'm not
speaking that out loud I'm not telling
him like what my plans are in my head so
he thinks that he's just speaking out
these problems and I'm not
telling him what I'm planning to do and
he's getting frustrated and he's a
hundred percent right
so what like why why wouldn't you just
tell him like hey there's a bigger issue
here the kids keep losing water bottles
and I don't feel comfortable continuing
to support their habit of not keeping up
with their things
and so if the kids keep losing their
water bottle they're making choices to
not have water bottles like what
prohibits you is it not safe to say that
or are you uncomfortable saying that
because I I think his complaint is is
dead on like he's saying hey we need to
grab we're out of water bottles I can
actually even see a moment where he
thinks he's helping
hey all the water bottles are gone when
you go to the store next time can you
grab a couple
and then you start a story in your head
an explanation and a narrative but you
don't share it and then you come back
and there's no water bottles and he
thinks my wife just ignores me she
didn't even say no she just said okay
and then nothing I see what I'm saying I
get what
what am I missing here yeah it's it's
like I feel like I
to it that I'll work on it in my time or
and I am not saying it out loud I'm just
thinking that I can handle it
but why are those Mutual why are those
mutually exclusive
like you can handle it clearly I mean
you can I mean you're you're smart and
accomplished you can do what you need to
do but why can't you also say it out
loud
I don't know I'm just
his bottles are
um same thing with like the kids
outgrown some clothes and they need some
new jeans and he mentions it and I'm
like okay yeah let me see first if we do
have enough pants before I go buy more
but I don't say it out loud I'm just
thinking like okay okay but you haven't
answered my question why
why am I doing that why are you not
saying that here here's the thing it
could be that every time you say
something he swears at you all right he
shoves you to the ground
and you have learned you better keep
your thoughts and opinions to yourself
because he's not safe that could be a
case
or it could be he's just the sweetest
guy on planet Earth and he's just like
trying to help out by pointing things
like by saying oh yeah hey I saw Timmy
the other day and his pants don't fit
we're gonna need to grab him some new
ones and because of the way you have
divided up your household he takes care
of some things you take care of other
things and those other things happen to
be kids clothes and
you just don't tell him
is is it safe for you to tell him things
um I feel like
the the way that he talks about things
he'll talk
um loudly or
not seem like easy to have a
conversation with some of the time okay
or depending on what the situation is
like the different issues so he'll get
loud and I'll he tells me that I get
defensive when he brings things up and
and I feel like he doesn't see that I am
working on something and
um and then if I say like oh yeah I've
done that or I help out here too and and
then he thinks that I'm just being
defensive and that he doesn't see that I
I am doing things and I I don't know
when he gets like loud in conversations
and feels like it's like I'm getting in
trouble for something then I either shut
down or
um just am not as easy to talk to
and you are right 100 on for that
the new language is
not just shutting down and disappearing
the new language is when he starts
yelling
you put up both hands until he stops for
a second and you say I am choosing to
not be in a conversation with somebody
that's treating me like I'm seven I'm
not your daughter
I'm choosing to not be in a conversation
with you if you're going to yell and
raise your voice
so I'm gonna take a break for 30 minutes
and if you want to re-engage this
conversation at a normal talking level
I'd love to do that
and then you walk away
okay is that safe to do
um I have like
why are you yelling right now no it's
not that's not helpful because here's
what here's why that's not helpful
because he is gonna feel that as an
attack because you are talking about his
behavior
when you put both of your hands up and
say I'm choosing to disengage the whole
conversations about you
here's what I'm gonna do
in Risk because I get to choose my
thoughts and my actions
you're raising your voice cool knock
your lights out I am not engaging in
that conversation has nothing to do with
yelling at him about him yelling or
pointing out what he's doing wrong
there's some great uh literature that
suggests even it was it was done with
some with political affiliation
um if someone has a political belief and
you show them empirically here is the
data that proves without a shadow of
doubt you're wrong
it actually
entrenches their view deeper
so if if someone was like all the
conservatives believe this that the Blue
Sky theory is liberal propaganda the sky
is green
and you literally got like a
spectrometer and you laid it out and
you're like no we just here look here's
NASA has done all this research the sky
is actually blue
somebody who's entrenched in that belief
because you're telling them they're
wrong they're thinking about something
wrong they're doing the wrong thing they
actually walk away thinking the sky is
greener than it was before
and so we're not gonna We're Not Gonna
lob grenades why are you doing this why
are you raising your voice because now
we're attacking even if you're right
he can't hear it because he's switched
parts of his brain
and so all I'm going to do is control
what I can control and control me
and if it's as simple as
hey let's have these conversations
here's what me and my wife do I can just
let me just tell you this way we have a
meeting once a week that talks about
calendar it talks about what the week's
going to look like and this is where my
wife just keeps a note card with her I
keep a note card with me and we write
things down to ourselves
uh Hank needs new clothes Josephine's
gonna have a thing for YMCA whatever and
we got this and we've got a thing coming
up and I'm gonna be on I took another
speaking gig I'm gonna be on the road
and so that when we get together and
talk about these things it's very
impassioned it's just math I mean it's
it's just we're just doing it like
having a business meeting basically
um turns out that meeting is like
foreplay right it's it's connection and
all these other things but it's just
like hey we need to do this it's gonna
cost 35 bucks for you to do this it
keeps it from being
hey you where were you today you were
late getting home and suddenly he goes
on the defensive and looks at you and
goes hey you got those new pants for
Timmy yet and you're like well I'm
thinking I'm working on it I just
haven't checked and now we're in a whole
you see what I'm saying now we're in a
whole fight
yeah now we're down a whole road that
we'd never had to get down right so it's
keeping those things both of y'all
agreeing to hey can we start having
these conversations at a scheduled time
every week write them down so that we
remember them and that way I can keep on
top of all these things and you can
begin to practice saying those stories
in your head out loud
is that something you can work on
yeah and it's been top of mind since we
kind of had this talk like a week ago
and he's we're trying to figure out like
in general like what do you need from me
yeah he says I need communication I need
more of it if I if you think that you're
doing it do more of it and I it it's
just like it I make up this excuse like
it's not it doesn't sound that easy to
do because it's not like a physical act
like to me like if my love language is
like
um
oh what is it spent quality time like
that's a physical act so that you can
actually do and see and so this one this
one is absolutely I think it's
absolutely a physical act
I think I think it is very much a
physical act I I think
for some reason and you and I could
probably spend like two hours talking
together I think there is
first whether it was something you've
been dealing with since you're a kid
whether it's something you have adopted
to to stay safe in your current
relationship or you had some boyfriend
in college who knows but for some reason
you don't feel safe your body doesn't
feel safe communicating
telling out loud hey here's what I
actually think about this or I hear you
say we need some more dental floss
pretty sure we have some in the basement
give me a minute I'm gonna go there and
check on it instead of just saying that
sentence you just say nothing
and that's speaking those things out
loud is communication that is a physical
act
and so here's what I want you to do I
want you to start practice saying it and
I want you to tell your husband it feels
weird I'm gonna try over communicating
when I have these thoughts in my head
I'm going to say them out loud and that
means sometimes you're going to say them
the wrong way
you're going to say them a little bit
sharper
you might say them in a way that hurts
his feelings and you need to tell him
while I'm practicing learning how to
over communicate
you have to promise that you will not
raise your voice
you have to promise that if I say
something the wrong way that comes
across as an attack to you that you will
take a big deep breath and exhale
and you won't come after me on it and
you will say thank you for communicating
and that way you're creating safe
boundaries while you practice this thing
it's the reason
um most NBA teams don't let camera crews
in during practice they're practicing
plays they're going to fall down they're
going to miss shots they're going to
miss dunks it's not the game
so you've got to create boundaries to
practice this because this is new for
you and you're going to feel awkward and
you're going to feel weird but I want
you to practice just saying things out
loud more and more get out of your own
head okay it is an action it is a
physical step and don't
um when he says I need more
communication and if you think you're
over communicating do it five times x
I don't want you to hear that and go oh
he must mean acts of service take him at
his word
and then if you're over communicating
and he starts to say well actually I
just want you to help me with okay well
now you're changing the tune but as for
right now
I think what's not working out in your
communication patterns is he's being
very direct with you saying his needs
out loud and you're hearing those needs
and you don't want to do what that need
is you want to do something else
and so my challenge to you is do what
you can to meet that need because I
don't think it's unreasonable and it's
not unreasonable for you to not be in a
conversation with somebody who's going
to raise their voice at you
it is not unreasonable for you to not
want to be romantic with somebody who
acts like your dad and that you're his
kid
it's not unreasonable for you to feel
unsafe if every time you push back a
little bit on something he yells and
gets mad or hits something or bangs on
something
and so we're going to step back together
and we're not going to do this across
the table at each other we're going to
be on the same side here and say okay
here's the problem is communication how
are we going to tackle this thing I'm
going to over communicate you're going
to treat me safely and now we're heading
off into a brand new relationship we'll
be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back hey thank you so
much for joining us on the Dr John
deloney show it still feels weird
talking about myself in the third person
how about this thank you so much for
joining us on the greatest podcast
mental health podcast ever I'm so
grateful for you don't forget to share
it don't forget to pick up the new
questions for humans and absolutely
transform your families and your
neighbors and your relationships we use
the question for humans cards last night
at dinner at Chuy's Mexican food
restaurant here in Nashville
and it was a blast I learned a lot of
things about my son and my daughter that
I did I did not know and I thought I
knew everything come to find out so hey
thank you so much for joining us we're
so grateful
um today's song of the day
I don't even care I like them I like him
I like Adele I like Beyonce I don't even
care I like Coldplay I like them I want
to go see him in concert throw my bucket
list how you like them apples America
and I do like Pantera but I like
Coldplay and I don't care the song is
fix you and it goes like this when you
try your best but you don't succeed when
you get what you want but not what you
need when you feel so tired but you
can't sleep stuck in reverse
and the tears come streaming down your
face when you lose something you can't
replace when you love someone but it
goes to waste could it be worse
lights will guide you home and ignite
your bones and I will try to fix you
and as we know on this show when you try
to fix somebody you love it never ever
works way to go Chris Martin hey I love
you guys we'll see you soon